got some live pictures now from the us
and i mean so many americans
a decision is uh implemented by states
my administration is going to focus on
how they administer and whether or not
they violate other laws
like deciding to not allow people to
cross state lines to get public health
services
and we're going to take actions to
protect women's rights and reproductive
health
this morning though i'm here we're here
to uh on a critical issue gun violence
now you know i'm about to sign the law
bipartisan safety net gun safety
legislation and time is of the essence
lies will be saved when returned from
europe jim and i will be hosting an
event in the white house on july 11 to
marcus this historic achievement
with members who voted for these
families and the families who in fact
were victimized by the gun shooting that
we've seen this over so
i i sound so incredible i've seen so
much of it of late
and uh and advocates have worked really
hard to do something about it
i've been at this work for a long long
time
and i know how hard it is and i know
what it takes to get it done
it was there i was there 30 years ago
the last time this nation passed
meaningful gun safety laws and i'm here
today for the most significant law to be
passed since then since the last 30
years
i'd like to thank the leaders and
members of the house and senate for
working together to get this done i
especially want to thank the families
and joe and i many of whom we sat with
for hours on end
across the country so many we've gotten
to know who lost their souls and to an
epidemic of gun violence they lost their
child their husband their wife
nothing is going to fill that void in
their hearts
but they led the way
so other families will not have the
experience and the pain and trauma that
they had to live through from columbine
to sandy hook to charleston orlando las
vegas parkland el paso atlanta buffalo
uvalde and for the shootings that happen
every day in the street that are mass
shootings we don't even hear about
the number of people killed every day in
the streets
their message to us was do something how
many times we heard that just do
something
for god's sake just do something well
today
we did
while this bill doesn't do everything i
want
it does include actions i've long called
for that are going to save lives
it funds crisis intervention including
red flag laws
it keeps guns out of the hands of people
who are a danger to themselves
and to others
and it finally closes what is known as
the boyfriend loophole
so if you assault your boyfriend or
girlfriend you can't buy a gun or own a
gun
it requires young people aged 18 to 21
to undergo enhanced background checks
it includes the first ever federal law
that makes gun trafficking and straw
purchases distinct federal crimes for
the first time it clarifies who needs to
register as a federally licensed gun
dealer
and run background checks before selling
a single weapon
you know this is also provides historic
funding to address youth mental health
crisis in this country especially
especially the trauma experienced by the
survivors of this gun violence
look
you know
invest in anti-violence programs at work
i work directly with the people who are
most likely to commit these crimes or
become victims of gun crimes
today
we say more than enough
we say more than enough
it's time when it seems impossible to
get anything done in washington we are
doing something consequential
we can reach compromise on guns
we ought to be able to reach compromise
and other critical issues from veterans
healthcare to cutting-edge american
innovation and so much more
i know there's much more work to do
and i'm never going to give up
but this is a monumental day
god bless us with the strength to
continue to work
to get the work that's left undone done
and the lives lost that can't be saved
that are obviously gone but will be an
inspiration for us to do more
i'm not going to sign this bill into law
these are live pictures from washington
where president
joe biden is signing into law what's
being described as the most significant
gun reform bill in decades
it's after congress passed the
law
and sent the bill to joe biden to sign
which he has done let's have a listen
i think the supreme court has made some
terrible decisions
from the supreme court will you will you
reconsider your previous opposition to
expanding the court sir what about term
limits for justices